Pennsylvania has 19, like tarts and selections.
That's why me and my best friend went to go canvas.
We hopped on a bus from New York City to acute headquarters
in an important swing district.
At the headquarters,
you get geared up with literature and talking points,
and paired with a local driver to head to your location.
On our way to our first house,
and both of us have never formally canvassed before.
First timer, so let's see how this goes.
And off we go.
There's a super easy app to download to help you navigate
as you walk through each neighborhood that you're canvassing.
Voters aren't home. We provide them literature to read on their own.
Sure, there's a couple Trump signs,
but there is way more Harris Waltz signs.
There are so many awesome volunteers out here every weekend,
building community for a better future.
It locked on, like,
I think 55 different doors today.
I think I'll definitely do it again.
It was an amazing first experience.
Was like, the topics that you think we heard the most.
The economy is what we heard the most.
Spoke to a lot of undecided voters,
which is kind of shocking to think about.
But, hey,
people. People were much more open to listening than I really expected.
Like, why we were out there,
and we would both explain our own stories.
I share. Just want people to mind their own business.
About my body. 10 out of 10 would Recommend.
But there's still weekends that people can go out and do this.
Three more weekend days left.
Oh, my god. Yes!
Trick or treating for votes.